the philosopher Ernest Becker famously
wrote a book called the denial of death
he talked about how human beings given
our Rich symbolic nature and
self-awareness cannot cope with the
ephemerality or finitude of Our Lives
the concept of mortality causes us so
much distress that we respond
symbolically by wanting to carve our
name on the tree wanting to do something
of value wanting to gain the recognition
of our peers because this becomes a kind
of symbolic immortality we may die but
our work will live forever now you give
us a tool like social media and you're
basically putting booster rockets on our
existential need to do something
meaningful and be recognized by others
our desire for immortality has gone into
overdrive on the back of social media
the need for virality the need for